défi de ces territoires merci la parole
est à monsieur dino cinieri matière
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre et j'associe l'ensemble
des parlementaires de mon groupe
monsieur le premier ministre la
situation des agriculteurs est intenable
et pendant ce temps votre ministre de
l'agriculture répète inlassablement que
tout va bien
partout en france des rassemblements ont
lieu quotidiennement pour dénoncer la
complexité des groupes contrôlent les
retards de versement du solde des aides
de la pac
les retards de versement de la totalité
des aides suite aux catastrophes
climatiques de l'été comme la chaise 13
qui a dévasté les monts du forez
monsieur le premier ministre que
faites-vous face à la détresse du monde
agricole
que faites vous pour faire remonter
rapidement les prix notamment du lait
alors que certaines enseignes de la
grande distribution font actuellement
des demandes de baisse de tarifs de -10%
qu'attendez vous pour mettre en place
des règles de commerce équitable
permettant de soutenir les produits
issus de l'agriculture française en
garantissant le jura juste prix pour le
producteur
pourquoi refusez-vous la mise en place
d'une tva rural pour réduire les charges
sociales des agriculteurs qui ne sont
pas éligibles au cic eu la semaine
dernière votre ministre de l'agriculture
annoncé le dépôt de mémorandum dont nous
n'avons pas eu le moindre détail et
s'est engagé à ce que le dossier des
prix agricoles soit abordé lors du
sommet hollande merkel du week-end
dernier
pouvez-vous nous apporter des précisions
sur ces deux points et où en sommes-nous
avec l'embargo russe
enfin monsieur le premier ministre quand
est ce que les enveloppes du fonds
d'allègement des charges
la prise en charge des cotisations
sociales ou encore l'année blanche
annoncé par le ministre le 26 janvier
sont notifiés au graff à la ddt et à les
aimer ça de façon à éviter un passage à
vide entre les aides 2015 qui n'ont pas
encore été toutes versées et celle de
2016 toutes ces rustines comme les
appelle xavier beulin sont
indispensables et urgentes
mais malheureusement elle ne réglons pas
des problèmes structurels que nous
appelons de nos voeux
et que votre majorité a rejeté jeudi
derrière l'enseigné
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt ce
président est monsieur le député j'ai
noté vous l'avez lu dans votre note que
j'aurais dit que tout allait bien en
agriculture je crois que là il ya ou il
méprise ou une erreur par définition
avec eux ce que nous avions annoncé avec
le premier ministre et en juillet et en
septembre et le plan de soutien qui se
met en oeuvre
c'est bien parce que on considère
nécessaire de venir aider les
agriculteurs qu'on a pris la mesure de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui je voulais
dix vingt mille dossiers sont déjà
traités 69 mille euros sont versés sur
la question de la sécheresse monsieur le
député et en particulier sur les monts
du forez 140 millions d'euros sont
devant celles déjà versées et je les dis
le 15 février
nous compléterons en fonction des
expertises qui seront données pour les
zones qui n'ont pas encore été éligible
vous parler monsieur le député et c'est
là que c'est important sur les
négociations commerciales et la manière
dont on pourrait vous l'avez évoqué agir
directement sur les prix mais je
voudrais vous rappeler monsieur le
député que nous vivons dans un cadre
législatif qui est celui de la loi de
modernisation de l'économie que vous
aviez tu teintant voté avec votre
majorité qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir
qu'on corrige ces éléments parce que
c'est là que se joue et c'est ce qu'on a
dit avec la grande distribution avec le
premier ministre hier c'est là que se
joue à sa blonde d'enjeux entre la
grande distribution et les industriels
par rapport aux producteurs et c'est là
qu'on a avec le premier ministre mis en
place une réunion avec emmanuel macron
dans la semaine pour faire en sorte
qu'entre les industriels la grande
distribution et les producteurs la
discussion tripartite ait lieu
c'est pas simplement de discussions
entre 1 du ciel et grands distributeurs
ça doit te dire compter prix